quel avenir désormais pour se sulfureux
groupe Wagner alors même que sa tête a
été décapitée nous allons en débattre
maintenant bienvenue Alexandra Jousset
vous êtes journaliste réalisatrice et
écrivaine spécialisée d'ailleurs dans
l'investigation on rappelle que vous
avez donc co-réalisé le documentaire que
nous venons de voir avec la journaliste
Xénia bolchava et ce travail vous a
d'ailleurs valu le Prix Albert Londres
en 2022 c'est le Graal de notre métier
dans la catégorie audiovisuelle et puis
elles Avida elle est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes vous aussi
journaliste rédactrice en chef de la
rédaction en langue russe de Radio
France Internationale après ce film il
s'est passé et c'est peu de le dire
beaucoup de choses concernant ce fameux
groupe Wagner on va juste rappeler que
le 24 juin dernier il y a une fronde du
côté de ce groupe Wagner qui a d'abord
marché sur une ville russe qui s'appelle
le Rostov
une ville de plus d'un million
d'habitants c'était surtout le centre
névalgique des opérations russes
concernant l'Ukraine et ce au nom de la
libération du peuple russe selon
evegaini prix gojin il voulait ramener
je le cite l'ordre dans le pays le 25 le
25 juin le lendemain il fait machine
arrière semble-t-il passer un accord
avec Moscou se fait exciter vers la
Biélorussie on retrouvera d'ailleurs sa
trace aussi en Afrique plus tard et puis
arrive ce fameux 23 août 19 2023 bien
sûr deux mois après où il trouve la mort
en compagnie d'outkin qui était son bras
droit au sein de Wagner on l'a très bien
vu d'ailleurs dans votre film avec ce
crash aérien il trouvera donc la mort
dans les conditions on ne peut plus
mystérieuse la première question que je
voulais vous poser après avoir vu ce
film avoir après avoir bien compris de
quoi était fait ce groupe Wagner est-ce
que vous aviez une seconde imaginez ce
scénario concernant la suite des
événements
c'est à dire la suite des événements si
c'est sur le fait de vouloir prendre le
pouvoir en Russie non on n'avait pas
imaginé et je pense que que peu de gens
avaient imaginer et gagner frigorne et
quelqu'un d'extrêmement imprévisible et
c'est justement aussi ce qui fait sa
force donc non on l'avait pas on pouvait
pas l'anticiper en revanche c'est
important de comprendre que c'est arrivé
à un moment critique pour Wagner c'est à
dire que gojin était en opposition
ouverte avec shoegoût le ministre de la
Défense russe et il multipliait les
vidéos où il investivait où il insultait
le ministre de la Défense russe et en
fait ce coup d'État n'est pas arrivé par
hasard c'est arrivé au moment où
Vladimir Poutine a tranché le débat
entre evegami Prigogine et shoegout qui
est un nom de la défense en disant que
Wagner devait s'arrêter une loi était
passée à la Douma il est société
militaires privées devaient déposer les
armes au 1er juillet il faut savoir que
Wagner était financé à hauteur des
milliards de d'euros de dollars pardon
par an de la part du gouvernement russe
plus et gagner Prigogine avait des
contrats d'État très juteux on pense
aussi hauteur d'un milliard avec les
services des armées tout ça les
s’arrêter du jour au lendemain donc si
vous voulez c'était un peu le chant du
signe quoi on se disait aussi qu'il
avait pas tellement d'autres options si
vous voulez que de se faire remarquer et
il faut noter que vous dites
pour je le cite libérer le peuple russe
il a pas marché sur Moscou il faut aussi
savoir que ressort sur le don c'est
aussi surtout la base de molkino qui est
là où il y a les mercenaires de Wagner
depuis le début donc c'était une région
si vous voulez acquise à la cause de
Wagner déjà bien avant ce qui avait
d'intéressant dans ce coup d'État et on
a mis un peu de temps le savoir et le
comprendre mais c'est que
vraisemblablement va devenir Poutine on
a été informé avant en tout cas les
services occidentaux les Français et les
Américains l'ont su avant donc il y a
peu de chances que le français et les
Américains sachant que Vladimir Poutine
le sache lui-même et du coup ça n'est
pas monté dans un bain de sang il n'y a
pas eu tout ça parce que probablement il
y a eu un travail du FSB il y a eu un
travail de tous les services autour de
Vladimir Poutine pour que ça ne se fasse
pas et pour qu'il n'y ait pas de bain de
sang qu'est-ce qu'il a gagné dans cette
affaire pour prigogne pas grand chose
sur le papier parce que le ministre de
la Défense russe est resté en place
l'absolution pour les troupes qui
avaient participé avec lui à cette
rébellion c'était ce qui avait été
promis par Moscou qu'est-ce qu'il a
gagné finalement à part de trouver la
mort de mois plus tard je pense que
c'est pas qu'il avait gagné à gagner
quelque chose c'est qu'il avait tout à
perdre avant de toutes les manières et
que c'est ça en fait qui s'est joué et
que lui pensait il faut imaginer qu'il
était quand même très proche d'un autre
général je suis désolé c'est un peu
technique qui s'appelle le général
soroviking qui était quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement respecté dans l'armée russe
et il se connaissent depuis toujours
puisque nous dans des documents internes
à Wagner on a trouvé que le général sur
Viking avait la médaille de Wagner et
qui sont combattu ensemble en Syrie
depuis 2015 et en fait il s'est
vraisemblablement cliquez sur ce Viking
et il pensait renverser shoegout et
prendre le pouvoir et prendre le
ministère de la Défense donc c'était ça
ce qu'il avait gagné ça n'a pas marché
ça c'est une certitude mais ensuite il a
cru qu'il pouvait négocier parce que
Vladimir Poutine avait besoin de lui
pour le sommaire russe Afrique qui avait
lieu en juillet Evelyne prigogne et
celui qui connaissait le plus intimement
le mieux les les les qui étaient
au pouvoir en Afrique et qu'ils aidaient
et du coup Vladimir Poutine avait encore
besoin de lui ensuite comment est-ce
qu'il a pu croire qu'il n'avait pas
mourir ça c'est une vaste question
est-ce que vous avez la même analyse sur
ce qui s'est passé sur le scénario
auquel on a on a assisté depuis le 24
juin dernier oui globalement je pense
que je partage tout à fait le point de
vue qu'Alexandra a déroulé je voudrais
juste mettre en exergue à un point pour
les téléspectateurs qui ont regardé le
documentaire c'est que en fait le en
attendant beaucoup en Occident a ramené
le système politique russe autour de
Vladimir Poutine et on a découvert avec
Wagner que en fait bon voilà il y avait
des institutions cachées qu'on nous
disait pas tout mais en réalité le champ
politique russe si on parle
d'institution est un champ où il y a
énormément de concurrence qui se jouent
entre les acteurs et au sein du
ministère de la Défense il y a plusieurs
courants donc
la mutinerie tentait pas pris goûté elle
sait faite sans doute en concertation
avec des gens comme soroviking et
d'autres membres des forces armées et
aussi les blogueurs qui avaient été
utilisés et attisés par le Kremlin et
ils ont fini par rassembler quelque
chose que moi j'ai commencé à appeler le
parti de la guerre où il y a les
ultrasnationalistes parce que là
l'idéologie qui est développée en Russie
pour justifier cette guerre mais
d'autres guerres aussi elle infecte en
retour la société elle la travaille et
donc il y a une demande de plus grande
efficacité et Wagner pour compléter un
peu ce que disait Alexandra avait quand
même servi à une chose c'est à masquer
globalement l'absence de victoire en
Ukraine de en ayant globalement réussi à
faire passer bar mouth pour une victoire
voilà donc et Solidar oui tout petit
bled à côté là donc bon c'est deux
points très limités sur la carte
ukrainienne donc il y a cette
concurrence et il y a cette violence et
maintenant il faut aussi se dire que en
fait Wagner était géré par prigogi avec
des commandants donc woodkin mais Wagner
est d'abord un projet militaire russe et
on nous a vendus Vladimir Poutine a les
yeux dans les yeux toujours nier
l'implication de l'époque très bien vu
dans le film d'ailleurs absolument mais
bon à nous de ne pas le croire mais on
n'avait aucune raison de le croire
particulièrement tout en ayant donc à
côté ce projet et qui n'est pas le seul
vaguemer n'est pas du tout la seule
compagnie militaire privée à se battre
en Ukraine en Syrie en Libye ou ailleurs
pour les tarus assigner des actions pour
les tarus il cette violence qui est
disséminée dans le système politique
russe alors Wagner décapité numéro 1
numéro 2 trouve donc la mort dans ce
crash d'avion et c'est vrai que
immédiatement à la lecture de ce qui a
pu être écrit au lendemain de ce cher et
on se dit qu'il y a deux options
possibles une dissolution complète de
Wagner ou alors une réorganisation sous
une nouvelle structure qui pourrait être
dirigée pourquoi pas par l'État central
russe
que pensez-vous de ces options la
dissolution c'est purement un peu ce que
je veux dire c'est que ils ont besoin
des hommes ils sont quand même dans un
conflit extrêmement meurtrier en Ukraine
ils ont besoin d'hommes qui savent se
battre nous rappeler combien d'hommes au
total
si tu vaguener aujourd'hui alors c'est
là où c'est plus compliqué de dire c'est
à dire que nous on a réussi à avoir des
listes de Wagner donc avant le conflit
c'était 10000 hommes qui étaient passés
par les rangs Wagner
on sait qu'il y en a eu 50 000 qui ont
été au-delà de 50 000 qui ont été
recrutés dans les prisons mais
évidemment si vous voulez il y a pas un
registre comme un registre des sociétés
avec les noms des gens voilà mais nous
les listes qu'on a réussi à avoir
c'était quand même au moins 10000
personnes on sait qu'en Afrique
aujourd'hui ils sont responsablement
autour de 2000 en Centrafrique 2000 au
Mali encore 1000 en Libye avec des
tentatives de déploiement ailleurs donc
ça fait quand même plus de 5000 hommes
sur le continent africain je vous ai
coupé mais sur les options possibles que
j'ai cité c'est que ce qui est très
important c'est de dire qu'on a besoin
de ces hommes donc la question c'est
exactement ce que vous disait c'est pas
la question de se dire est-ce que pour
qui vont combattre ou sous quel voilà
ils vont être là ils vont continuer à
combattre pour les tarus
soit dans des corps d'armée est une
éventualité pour ceux qui le souhaitent
soit dans d'autres sociétés militaires
privées on voit qu'on veuille redoute
toutes ces sociétés qui existaient déjà
avant sont maintenant redéployés en
Afrique en Afrique il y avait vraiment
peu d'autres sociétés militaires privées
que Wagner mais il y avait d'autres ce
que vous disiez est-ce que cabinet
appelle les entrepreneurs d'influence il
y avait d'autres oligarques qui étaient
qui étaient proches et qui est aussi
s'intéressait
à l'Afrique et donc il y en a d'autres
très bien qui peuvent arriver reprendre
le combat si je puis dire et on voit le
l'ancien patron des unités du GRU André
off je suis jamais contria peut-être
vous aider
exactement
russe Afrique en juillet dans une
Evelyne Prigogine était là mais il n'a
pas eu le droit d'assister
officiellement aux rencontres et même
Vladimir Poutine a demandé au chef
d'État africain comme Faustin Archange
choix des rats de ne pas rencontrer et
gagner prigogi officiellement ce qui
était quand même un camouflé mais dans
les réunions officielles il a unronisé
ce nouveau chef dont on pense que c'est
celui dont il faudrait qu'il reprenne la
direction des opérations peut-être en
Afrique de l'Afrique tout à l'heure il
en est un qui s'est tôt trop pour clamer
nouveau chef de Wagner il s'agit
d'antones
4 si il faut le donner des numéros
hiérarchique
chez Wagner c'était le numéro 4 il
n'était pas dans l'avion il s'est craché
le 23 août dernier
c'est lui le successeur pour le moment
c'est tout porte à croire que à la tête
de Wagner tout porte à croire qu'en tout
cas il va être sous le nom de lotus
connu comme le porte étendard celui à
qui on va demander des comptes et qui va
représenter
comme presque tout le monde en a dans ce
genre de compagnie mais
la capacité à s'autoproclamer il a en
fait ça marche pas du tout comme ça pour
le peu qu'on en sache il y a quand même
une forme comme on le voit dans d'autres
sociétés militaires privées ou des
compagnies de mercenaires il y a une
forme de collégialité dans les décisions
qui sont prises un peu aussi comme on
pouvait le voir chez les corsaires un
parallèle qui peut être utile puisque ce
sont des gens mandatés pour exercer de
la puissance pour une autorité
officielle et qui s'autorégulent et qui
partagent donc il y a un partage de
l'autorité et de la décision au sein du
collège de commandant de Wagner donc ici
c'est lotus qui a été mis en avant c'est
qu'il y a a priori un accord interne qui
a été atteint maintenant ce qui est très
important
sa succession
cette vidéo n'est pas sortie pour le
moment ce que je redresse dont on parle
aurait été désigné par trigogine
absolument mais je me rappelais deux
choses d'abord dans le système politique
et dans la vie publique russe presque
tout le monde a un réflexe de ce défier
des versions officielles donc on se dit
mais il y a cette vidéo il y a sans
doute des compromates qui existent
peut-être n'est-il pas mort parce que la
parole publique est tellement connotée
comme un mensonge qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à croire à une quelconque version et
donc nous les journalistes nous faisons
un travail de recherche le plus
documenté possible parfois il y a des
moments comme dans votre documentaire où
on a accès à des sources à des témoins
extraordinaires mais le plus clair de
notre temps sur ce niveau de décision
nous croisons des sources nous n'avons
pas accès aux sources direct donc on en
vient à analyser ce qui est le plus
plausible et probable dans l'état de
notre connaissance mais le système russe
en ce moment il est soumis à une
transformation intense du fait de la
guerre on est moi c'est pas du tout
capable de prédire la mutinerie de
trigogine je j'en ai été extrêmement
surprise la mort était un peu plus
logique étant donné les pratiques russes
esquisses étaient permis de faire mais
on avance on s'adapte véritablement au
cours d'événements qui sont sortis du
cadre habituel donc sans doute Lotus
est-il à l'heure actuelle le
représentant le gestionnaire de Wagner
c'est à dire des hommes Wagner mais il y
a averianov qui est le curateur c'est à
dire la cheville ouvrière la jonction
entre le groupe et les institutions de
l'État auxquelles il répond et encore
une fois il faut pas se laisser tromper
c'est un projet militaire russe tout
comme redoute tout comme convoi koudou
comme d'autres et il y a elles répondent
à l'État central russe il y en a
d'autres qui répondent à gaz Prom à
d'autres grandes entités à des
oligarques mais il faut aussi savoir que
dans le système russe les oligares qui
sont effectivement très puissants et il
y en a très peu en réalité aujourd'hui
c'est un terme dévoyé ils ont pour
fonction dans l'état de garder des
poches d'argent et ces poches d'argent
maintenant en ce moment depuis le début
de la guerre il les mette à ma
disponibilité de l'État c'est à ça
qu'ils servent et dans le cas de la
guerre en Ukraine face à la difficulté
intense ils ont créé ou alimenter ses
compagnies ils sont là pour venir
compenser les faillites du système
militaire officiel rongé quand même par
une corruption rampante quand il y a une
grande réforme de l'armée en 2008 en
Russie le responsable de cette réforme a
été démissionnée c'est un ministre
démissionner très peu de temps après
parce qu'il s'était enrichi
frauduleusement donc l'armée est rangée
par une corruption rampante les sociétés
militaires privées le son de manière
factice et elle rendent les services que
l'armée ne peut pas rendre ce groupe
Wagner vous dites dans le documentaire
que nous de voir repose sur un triptyque
se battre s'enrichir des informer et on
parle souvent d'une galaxie Prigogine
l'héritage il est là il considérable
c'est héritage pris d'origine il va bien
au-delà du simple groupe paramilitaire
dont on parle la police
héritage et
il regroupe quoi très exactement elle
regroupe quoi cette galaxie privilégiée
dont on parle si souvent c'est surtout
des médias des blogueurs il y avait il y
a rien fan qui est un grand groupe de
presse avec près de 450 aussi au titre
de presse locaux ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que on a vu après la
mort de Prigogine les fermatrols
continuent à publier des informations
donc ça veut dire que ça continue et et
c'est exactement pour grandir ce que
vous dites c'est que c'est pour moi la
preuve que on avait confié à prix gojine
un projet d'État en fait et que il y a
une continuité et que tout ça va
continuer et que quand on met pris gojin
sur la liste des mandats d'arrêts
américains pour cette
Gémeaux en anglais medle mais cette
mélanger enfin avoir voulu interrompre
ou interférer
en effet avec les élections américaines
en fait c'est l'État russe qu'on vise et
il y avait cette espèce d'hypocrisie
totale qui maintenant est complètement
levée et qui a même été levé ce que je
voulais rajouter par Vladimir Poutine
lui-même parce que dans sa conférence de
presse il a sorti les chiffres c'est lui
qui a dit combien il financait c'est lui
il a déroulé la genèse de Wagner il a
dit on l'a créé on l'a financé c'est
notre projet et donc il reconnaît
ouvertement son projet antioxydant il
reconnaît ouvertement que les élections
américaines c'est lui il reconnaît
ouvertement que la propagande anti
française en Afrique c'est lui c'est une
déclaration de guerre totale en fait et
il a reconnu vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure notamment avoir financé Wagner à
hauteur d'un milliard de dollars entre
2022 et 2023
c'était quand on nous on avait récupéré
les budgets de désinformation c'était
incroyable l'argent il faut imaginer
qu'ils ont des ferma trolls au Mexique
ils ont des fermatrols dans toute
l'Europe on avait trouvé des traces en
Allemagne en France enfin c'était un
projet considérable et d'ailleurs ce
qu'il y a de ce qu'il y a de fou c'est
que quand on commence à s'intéresser à
Wagner nous-mêmes on n'avait pas
conscience de de ce projet de cette
tentacule de sa on se disait c'est pas
possible que ça soit aussi gros et plus
on tirait à la plage plus on se disait
mais c'est ils sont partout et en fait
ils ont des petites initiatives locales
ils sont très adaptables donc ça veut
dire que dès qu'ils ont vu que ils
étaient arrêtés parce qu'ils étaient
fait prendre par le FBI et que leur
tentatives de faux groupe Black live
matters avait été repère assez
rapidement et ben ils ont complètement
changé de stratégie ils ont recruté des
fermats locales qui ne savaient pas
qu'elle travaillait pour les Russes
c'était une autre enquête qu'on avait
faite après on avait retrouvé des gens
qui nous disaient mais non mais moi je
pensais que je travaille pour des
Français ils s'étaient déguisés donc ils
sont très adaptables et de croire que le
projet va mourir avec elle c'est
vraiment la plus grande des erreurs
alors on a évoqué tout à l'heure le nom
d'Andreï averianov officier du GRU c'est
le service du renseignement militaire
russe chargé très souvent d'ailleurs des
bases œuvres auprès de Vladimir Poutine
on a évoqué son nom et cette
personnalité pour reprendre les
activités de Wagner en Afrique et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure il y a pas
tant que ça de société privée qui sont
très actives en Afrique à part Wagner
Wagner en Russie qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir
est-ce que ça va garder la même forme
est-ce que ça va à nous ça va
s'amplifier au gré des volontés de
l'État russe justement comment vous
voyez les choses alors ce qu'on peut à
peu près dire c'est que
pour ce qui est en tout cas des hommes
de Wagner ce qui a été proposé
officiellement c'était pour ceux qu'ils
souhaitaient de rejoindre les troupes du
ministère de la Défense ou les troupes
de la garde nationale
la garderie et par ailleurs l'armement
lourd a été transférée ou deux vais être
transféré aussi à la gare de russe qui
est géré par un homme qui s'appelle
zolotov qui est aussi lui un proche un
homme bien sûr
issu des services de sécurité de l'État
ce qu'on pourrait appeler l'état profond
pour le coup en Russie et c'est ça la
destinée officielle de Wagner en Russie
mais Wagner rend essentiellement ses
services à l'étranger en Russie est
resté des activités médiatiques les
activités de déstabilisation aussi
Internet et puis le l'Empire commercial
qu'avait créé trigogine ladite en
passant un peu avant sa rencontre avec
Poutine puis après qui était devenu
florissant avec un système de prédation
aussi on l'a vu en Centrafrique avec ce
film
dans les mines d'or les mines de
diamants notamment c'est une forme de
rémunération pour ce groupe ça ça va
perdurer elle est mine d'or évidemment
on voit pas les Targus renoncer à un
accès à des ressources aussi importants
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que en échange des services rendus aux
apprentis puccins
tout simplement les tarus n'est pas
n'est pas en capacité les États
africains ne sont pas en capacité de
payer en revanche ils permettent à
l'État russe de se payer sur la bête et
ça pour les tasses c'est une manne et
les tarus ne tient pas non plus à payer
Wagner ou redoute ou les autres donc
c'est sûr les pays africains les
ressources des sociétés africaines que
le paiement va s'effectuer c'est tout à
fait idéal à la fois pour les dirigeants
russes et aussi pour les dirigeants
africains qui font le pari de s'appuyer
sur Wagner ou sur d'autres compagnies
militaires privées encore une fois il
faut pas se leurrer ce à quoi on fait
face c'est une poussée russe à
l'international pour fragiliser toutes
nos positions dans nos démocraties dans
les espaces que nous que nos États ont
tendance à considérer comme des zones
d'influence et nous sommes en
confrontation avec le système russe si
aujourd'hui nous ne l'avons pas encore
compris je pense que il faut regarder
plus d'enquêtes comme ce documentaire
mais je pense c'est tout à fait évident
l'Ukraine est une confrontation avec le
système démocratique ce que la Russie
devl Vladimir Poutine ne veut pas c'est
ce qu'elle appelle une contagion entre
guillemets de la démocratie donc il est
important pour elle de montrer que une
Ukraine démocratique n'aura pas lieu la
Géorgie est aussi en train d'être
soumise à dépression pro russe parce que
l'évolution vers un système démocratique
n'est pas souhaitable à Vladimir Poutine
la Russie a échoué depuis les années 90
à développer un système attractif elle
s'en remet donc à ce qu'elle sait faire
des opérations de déstabilisation et on
voit des hommes qui sont issus de ce
système gérer cela chatigo qui est donc
maintenant le ministre de la Défense et
télécharger des négociations avec
l'apresie en Géorgie en 93 pour le
compte de la Russie où on faisait déjà
croire que
les Géorgiens c'était autobombardé donc
les discours qu'on a pu entendre comme
effectivement Navalny c'est Toto
empoisonné c'est exactement le même type
de rhétorique et je finirai par vous
dire qu'avériane offre au grue il était
avant cela chargé d'une unité
d'opération spéciale et il est largement
soupçonné d'être derrière l'opération
d'empoisonnant de scripal en
Grande-Bretagne oui puis pour aller dans
votre sens
ce général dirige l'unité du GRU chargé
des assassinats et des missions de
déstabilisation à l'étranger
effectivement il y a des raisons de fait
de le soupçonner de cette assassinat de
pris gojin dans le cadre de ses
fonctions officielles c'est ce qu'il
sait faire Wagner en Afrique l'important
c'était c'était une de très longue
séquence difficile à obtenir j'imagine
sur place
l'avenir de Wagner en Afrique vous êtes
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit là
vous voulez compléter les choses tout à
fait non je pense que Wagner parce que
pendant au début de l'offensive en
Ukraine on s'est demandé qui allait
venir de l'Afrique on a beaucoup regardé
les mouvements de troupes savoir s'ils
allaient si vous voulez enlever des
troupes en Afrique pour les envoyer vers
l'Ukraine et en fait on s'est rendu
compte que non il y a eu un mouvement au
début mais en fait pour eux l'Afrique
est stratégique et donc au contraire
maintenant on voit plus de mouvements
dans l'autre sens arriver en Afrique et
surtout on les voit et c'est conquérir
des nouveaux territoires ils étaient
tout de suite au Burkina Faso on sait
qu'ils essayent d'aller en Érythrée pour
construire un port là-bas partout ou si
vous voulez il y a des signes de
faiblesse ils arrivent ils essayent de
prendre du pouvoir ils essaient de
gagner du terrain donc pour eux c'est un
enjeu majeur et qui ne compte pas du
tout abandonner et d'ailleurs que le
nouveau que le nouveau soi-disant patron
Wagner en tout cas celui qui donc le
général du GRU se rendent deux fois en
moins d'un mois en Libye aux côtés du
maréchalaftal c'est dire l'importance
que ça pour eux si vous voulez de
signifier leur présence et de reprendre
en main de système en Afrique bon on
verra de quoi ça fait
l'avenir de ce groupe Wagner on a essayé
d'en parler d'en discuter après ce
formidable documentaire vous allez
réaliser en
2022 et co-réalisé merci à toutes les
deux d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
consacré à l'avenir du groupe Wagner
après votre formidable documentaire qui
avait été réalisé en 2022 il s'est passé
c'est vrai beaucoup de choses depuis la
réalisation de de votre enquête vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
j'imagine qu'elles seront nombreuses
vous pourrez bien sûr l'une et l'autre
réagir à ce que seront c'est réactions
merci à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et je vous donne rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]